- So the second craziest
Trump surrogate lawyer,
question mark,
LinWood,
who has been filing all
sorts of crazy lawsuits
and ai a QAnon conspiracy peddler,
has been making all kinds
of crazy accusations about John Roberts,
the Chief Justice of the Supreme Court.
Woods says that Roberts knew
that Scalia was going
to die before he did.
That Roberts arranged
an illegal adoption of two young children
from Wales through Jeffrey Epstein.
And then Woods questions whether
John Roberts skipped a day
of defamation class,
implying that the allegations are true.
Therefore not subject to defamation.
So the question is,
are these allegations
subject to defamation?
And the answer is almost certainly yes.
Chief Justice Roberts is
not going to sue Lin Woods.
He probably doesn't know who Lin Woods is.
But these are the kinds
of verifiable provable facts
that could definitely give
rise to a defamation claim.
So if you found this interesting or sad,
check out my other Eagle briefs
where I talk about the legal news.
I'll see you in court.